three things I would do if I were king
when I'd be benevolent but firm and I
don't expect to be king but I would like
the country to look at entitlement
reform in a serious way now what I mean
by that when I look at America I don't
see an under tax nation I see a nation
struggling to create jobs in a global
economy that's changed forever and we're
over promising as a nation we made
promises to future generations we can't
keep so what would I do if I could I
would set Republicans and Democrats down
and fix Social Security because that is
eminently doable I would change the age
of retirement we're living longer that's
the good news the bad news is these
entitlement programs haven't had the
age-adjusted so I would move the age
somewhere in the 69 range slowly over
time for people under 55 it would not
affect people on social security or near
retirement I would also ask people of my
income level to take less and benefits
because the promises we've made and to
future generations of Americans are
unsustainable we've got three workers
for every social security retiree today
in 20 years we'll have to when i was
born in 55 we had 16 for every retiree
so we're having less people in more
retirees living longer so i would adjust
the age and i would recalculate benefits
for people in my income level the second
thing i would do for the country is i
would create a legal infrastructure that
would allow our country to be at war but
within our values the CIA no longer
interrogate seeeeee terror suspects I'm
not for waterboarding but I'm also not
for taking the CIA I the interrogation
business the Army Field Manual is the
only document we have now to interrogate
enemy combatants people suspected of
terrorism somewhere between the army
field manual which is published online
and waterboarding which i think is a bad
way to interrogate people we should find
a middle ground allow the CIA to do
enhanced interrogations within our
values but not till the enemy what's
coming their way I would make sure that
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed the mastermind of
nine
is tried in military commissions he's
been held under the law of war for six
or seven years I think it's a mistake to
put him in civilian court we're at war
were fighting a war on auto crime which
leads me to energy policy we use more
mideast all today more dependent on
Mideast oil today than we were before
nine eleven that's a national security
nightmare so what I'd like to do is the
third thing is to become energy
independent create jobs in low-carbon
technologies like wind solar and nuclear
and the third thing is clean up the air
if my generation of political leaders
could break our dependency on foreign
oil create a low-carbon economy that
would allow America develop technology
and create new jobs for future
generations and pass on to the future
generations cleaner air that would be a
pretty good use of my time